At least
two people are dead
and at least 30 wounded
after a Russian attack hit
medical science
in the Ukrainian city of the Dnipro
Hospital. Was among the sites damaged.
The mayor said it's a miracle.
Doctors were changing shifts
when the attack happened.
It means that fewer people were working
at the time. Of the strike.
Sirens could be heard over.
Keefe
and sirens
just heard that happening
as drone and missile strikes
occurred overnight.
Ukraine says it
shot down ten missiles and over 20 drones
across the border.
The Russians are reporting more attacks
inside the Belgorod region further away.
An explosion
has been reported in the Russian city
of Krasnodar.
Social media video
appears to show a drone
flying above the city.
Moments later,
there is some kind of blast.
Fred Pleitgen is in Ukraine's capital,
Kiev.
Let's talk
more about the attack
on this medical facility.
Fred, we know that two people are dead.
Just walk us through
what happened and just sort of
set the scene for us in terms
of what you know so far
Yeah, this
happened in the early
morning hours of this morning
as it happened.
As you already
very correctly
put it, as
there were air strikes going on
Russian strikes
throughout the country,
throughout Ukraine here, in fact,
in the early morning hours.
And overnight,
we did hear sirens here in Kiev.
And we also heard
the air defenses here around Kiev at work
at well as well.
The strike on Dnipro happened
a little bit later
in the morning hours of this morning,
and it hit that medical facility,
which also has a veterinarian facility
nearby as well.
And some of the video
that was coming out of that area
in the early stages
was just absolutely horrifying
where injured people
were trying to save themselves
and get out of that building.
People were helping them get out.
A lot of people drenched
in blood, essentially.
And then, of course,
you have that total of 30 people
who were injured,
a lot of them still in hospital,
some of them in quite critical condition.
And two people who have been killed now.
The latest that we have
from the Ukrainians
is they say
that they believe
that for this strike
that hit that medical facility
that ballistic missiles were used
on the part of the Russians, either
S-300 or S-400 missiles.
And just to put that
into context for our viewers.
Those are missiles
that are normally used
to shoot down airplanes.
However,
they also have a mode
where they can be used against
ground targets
in a surface to surface configuration.
However,
when you use them that way,
they become extremely inaccurate.
And of course,
if you
then use them to shoot
into an urban area,
the kind of things happen
that happens today
where this is
a medical facility was hit and,
you know,
it was
obviously pretty much
completely destroyed.
A big fire broke out.
Rescue crews are still on the scene
looking to see whether
there are further survivors or people,
some maybe still buried
beneath the rubble there.
So a major strike.
It's been condemned
by Ukraine's president,
by the first lady of Ukraine,
by countries internationally as well.
But, of course,
that is something that we've seen
very frequently here in Ukraine.
But we've had these massive
missile strikes across the country
that in some cases have also hit civilian
facilities as well Zain.
Fred Pleitgen live for us there.
Thank you so much.
CNN's
Jim Colby has just arrived
and joins us live now
So, Sam, here's the thing.
The mayor was saying
that doctors
were actually changing their shift
when this strike happened,
and that's a miracle
because it meant that
fewer people were actually working
Just talk
talk us through
what you're seeing
and hearing on the ground there.
Well, saying it was a fluke
if there's any good fortune
in this very gruesome outcome.
But the scale of the
devastation on this
building is quite obvious.
This was not one of those
Iranian side drones
carrying a mere 40 kilograms of high
explosive, deadly.
Those they they are
they've been supplied in vast quantities
to the Iranians,
by the Iranians, to the Russians.
This is something quite different.
There's been some speculation
by government officials here
that this may have been an S-300,
which is an enormous
traditional anti-aircraft missile,
but it's been used increasingly
ruthlessly by the
excuse me,
by the Russians against civilian targets.
Now, this is a medical facility, Zain,
And as such would be more than 40 other
medical facilities
have been hit
in the course
of just over a year of this war.
Prosecuted by Russia against Ukraine.
The French government, among others
in the international community, have said
that the targeting of medical facilities
amounts to a war crime.
Now, the Russians could
perhaps argue that this
is an accident due to poor targeting,
but it is also
in a densely populated residential area.
If you just look over here,
behind this fence here, a block of flats
and other block of flats,
they're not a block of flats there.
It's all a residential area.
There's even
a football pitch being built
just over here, a soccer pitch,
I should say.
And this is what the Russians are intent
on doing.
Taking down
and destroying a medical clinic.
More than 40
others have been destroyed or attacked
by Russia. Over the last year.
And we saw this,
of course,
during the Syrian civil war,
continue to see, indeed,
where the Russians
are also operational
in both contexts,
certainly in the Syrian context,
the absolutely systematic,
deliberate targeting
of medical facilities. They
And just looking
behind you, I mean, certainly
a grim task ahead for rescue crews,
as they may indeed
still be looking for people
who might be trapped in the rubble.
Some highlight for us.
They're in deep trouble
on the ground
outside that medical facility
that was just attacked. Sam, thank you.